there's a new Caped Crusader
there's a new amazing web slinger and
now there's a new hero who dares to be
wimpy there's one thing I've learned
from my years of being a kid that you
have zero control of your own Mike was
excited about the great Heffley road
trip from 20th Century Fox a new
generation of wimps hits the road meet
Greg you are one Oh Greg I wouldn't
encourage them there's only one Roderick
I got a microwave pizza
Roger that's a mini safe and they
disguise it as a microwave rally
Minnie how about them son you want my
brain fries oh my gosh mom and dad first
rule of a road trip is the driver is the
DJ this summer it's perfect
new places clear expose in Indianapolis
this weekend is only two inches away for
sure that's a nice work changing
destination new faces I'm gonna cut it
what you guys do we're in trouble
[Music]
oh look out you the pigs better potty
training you Greg oh my god
Diary of a Wimpy Kid the long haul road
trip four days in car together this
summer
Claire Expos in Indianapolis this
weekend is only she